you know i still use ass jeeves
get the [ __ ] out of here not even joking
just cuz to be funny yeah you because
we're hanging out you're telling me
stuff that you do and i was just
laughing i'm like
you approach life like like a comedy
and more people need to do that i need
to do that you made me realize how
serious i take life and i'm a [ __ ]
idiot
the whole [ __ ] you were talking about
like faking phone calls that was so
goddamn funny yeah this is hilarious
ask jeeves yeah good website
i endorse yo ask jeeves ask jeeves
how much
is a cheeseburger at red robin you know
what i think he's gonna say things and
say depending on what it is yeah if it's
if it's the southwest
crispy onion burger i'm gonna guess it's
about 9.99
if i was a betting man
[Laughter]
what does jeeves have for us here bro it
still comes back in raw text that's
amazing
what are you trying to do is is that an
insult to this site no i'm i'm serious
all right guys [ __ ] i hate how
evolved like google and [ __ ] is where
it's got 45 [ __ ] ads
you can't trust any of the results
because they're all paid for or indexed
from like 20 years ago i like that this
[ __ ] is just lo-fi you just get text
back get in get out with jeeves yeah
[ __ ] geez hire hunter man
i would i would gladly i'd do it for
free
if they if they literally send me a
shirt i'd probably i'd wear it in every
video i did
they have the worst logo
i've ever seen and if it was a
compressed jpeg on a shirt i would wear
it every day of my life
i would ruin my marriage over it
hold up bro do you remember when we're
going to the cheesecake factory dress up
i got my jeeps look at that look at that
bass drum no [ __ ] this
god damn what happened to the no type in
ask jeeves mascot on google
he looks you look good i bet they lost
the
probably too fancy for him now
what font is that that that is like some
yeah powerpoint font yeah papyrus
something from
areas like a little dapper boy yeah why
is that [ __ ] not on the actually that
second image is actually horrifying
the parade 3d thing is that a parade god
damn
damn how do they get jesus to do that
yeah my dad's like whoa
he's a big [ __ ] how's that big
boy fly like that
no it's uh it's just a it's a thing
filled yeah we're all filled with gases
you know and water
[Laughter]
yeah that's cheese yeah no not a lot of
people use ask jeeves anymore it's a
shame what's the last thing you found on
ask jeeves i think i i think i literally
googled a uh or not googled ashley
achieved yeah well google's become such
a verb now um you know but i've achieved
yeah
it doesn't work really i asked jeeved
about jeeves about a uh
about a maddie matheson recipe
okay what was the recipe
it was like a uh
it was a piece of some kind of meat yeah
it's just a fancy name that you you kind
of like it looks good i'd never remember
any of it though yeah but it looks good
and he makes it look good yeah you like
maddie matheson
um
i don't think i've ever i don't even
think i've seen maddie madison's face
really yeah he's very handsome let me
see
and he has quite the style if you're if
you're a large lad i'd recommend looking
at maddie mathis and he is quite maybe i
have seen him i probably have i'm just
lying to myself oh yeah
yeah
yeah he's a fantastic chef
and one hell of a personality yeah
i take back what i said i love this dude
it's convenient
did i say i hate him i'll take that back
yeah you know what never mind i'm going
back no i'll take it back flip flop
that's all you got to do really when you
have a bad opinion
you just like get in front of the crowd
i'm glad you're so experienced with that
yeah to let people know that that's
exactly what you need to do
no you just you just go did i say that
at least unless you have the like at
least you have the knowledge of that
yeah i feel like a lot of people just
take the opinion they have and they
don't really think about
anything else besides
not what they're thinking
i i i [ __ ]
i'm
too
conscious of the 45 different angles
someone could perceive what i say
are you concerned about getting dragged
online
not not dragged per se i just want to
make sure that i'm thorough when i speak
you know
speaking of like influencing people the
wrong way i get really paranoid about
that too like if i phrase something yeah
yeah like in like a in an inaccurate or
incorrect way like i was trying to recap
the ending of like the formula one
season
if we seize you in [ __ ] london we're
gonna cut your [ __ ] head off like
he's a dead man i was just trying to do
it like in an abridged way because
everyone listens to this pocket i don't
give a [ __ ] about cars
and
i some kid just like lit me up he's like
me [ __ ] you biased [ __ ] you
retold that so
you know like one sided this and that
i'm like
man [ __ ] that like i guess you can try
as hard as you can you're still gonna
piss somebody off but yeah yeah i'ma
[ __ ] them
if somebody messages you that like dude
who the [ __ ] are you two i mean yeah
ultimately what yeah i don't care
because i know i put my best foot
forward but it's just like it's like
going to like a random dude like you
overheard a conversation
at like target
you're like by the way dude [ __ ] you
yeah
well i do i don't even
what i heard all that [ __ ] you said
about mighty joe young being [ __ ] a
fake gorilla yeah exactly that shit's
real dude they train those monkeys to do
that you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about my guy they're extinct now
too though there's big ones
it's a way nice take dude
what's his dad's name dude i wanna i'm
like i wanna find him
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
i definitely
reflect way too much sometimes
do you ever get that like when you make
your art do you ever i feel like you're
definitely pretty good about just me
like man [ __ ] it i'm gonna do what i'm
gonna do i think that as long as
especially with any kind of like
creation i think even if it isn't
something super
like
artistic like somebody would say like
you know a painting is probably more
artistic than like
i don't know like some regular youtube
videos or something like that yeah i
think as long as your intention
is like non-malicious then usually i
think that that's like
i think that's all you have to worry
about yeah yeah i mean because as long
as you're conscious about that and
you're like honest about that i think
that no matter what you make even if
people
are upset by it's because they don't
understand it yeah yeah that's fine it's
fine for people not to understand things
but at the same time
it's uh fine for people to also enjoy it
yeah so yeah that's why when i'm just
like
uh
just
incredibly mean it's just like
it's not mean it's just
you just don't understand you know
that's my cop-out well that's fine
that's what i've absorbed yeah that's
good
people are very rude online oh yeah they
are
it's kind of impressive though like you
ever read something that's so [ __ ]
mean just about anyone you're like damn
oh dude [ __ ]
man that is something this whole chant
like whole communities and channels is
based around like bullying people and
[ __ ] and like all that kind of stuff
yeah you look at things it's horrible
and but at the same time like this is
like a crusade yeah
this is like you're fighting a holy war
that probably you're gonna regret later
in time do you think that's how they see
themselves like the knights of templar
like we must yeah i think people have
really dumb ways of rationalizing
like stuff of like grand
i don't know what is it grand sizing
people i use words a lot i really don't
know what they mean that's okay because
it just sounds good
i and i i've done that with my friends
they're like you know we kind of stop
just like we kind of understand the way
you speak now even if something makes no
sense we kind of get the understanding
of what you're trying to say
so i'll just yeah just say just some of
your friends and you're gonna say my
sonic the hedgehog bit is condescending
there's time and history with that
[ __ ] picked me up and he's
talking about cabbo and now he's calling
me a hedgehog and [ __ ] hey listen how am
i supposed to take all this also you go
i was like
where do you want to go for dinner yeah
remember you said that yeah and i was
like let's just go to
let's just go to like uh let's get grab
some wings and watch the game
he's like well i'm not this place is a
michelin star but i guess i'll cancel
the reservation made me feel bad yeah
that's exactly what i said actually i
thought i thought that maybe they had
the game in the bathroom or something
yeah no it's like hey you want to grab i
don't drink yeah all sorts of stuff
making me just feel bad left and right
but i was there you know chiefs one yeah
no hunter was like uh let's just grab
some wings i'm like fine and i had to
text the chef and i was like put the
octopus back in the ocean exactly and
then there's just no don't put him back
put him in a ziploc bag suffocate that
bastard and then just throw it out yeah
exactly and put it in the trash and i'm
gonna come by later yeah and i'm gonna
kick it and then i'll go home yeah
exactly just kick him once yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
just a couple
[Laughter]